the death of Queen Elizabeth II has
reignited the conversation about
Britain's Colonial past now because of
that history feelings about her Legacy
are mixed in many places particularly in
Britain's former colonies DW's Felix
Moringa went to the hotel in Kenya where
she heard she was Queen and as you'll
see in the report it's also near where
British soldiers later carried out
atrocities against Independence fighters
in the country
this is where princess Elizabeth became
Queen she was staying in the original
Treetops hotel in Kenya's aberdare
National Park when she was told her
father had died making her the monarch
in the reception of the rebuilt Hotel a
book of condolence for guests to write
their comments Amos nagua a guide who
works there says his father cooked for
Elizabeth when she stayed here in 1952.
Queen Wall is very talkative to the
cooks with us and they could always call
all their stuff around who are working
in the hotel and then
and get them together and give them a
tip and they were very happy when the
staff are given money then they go and
help their families so they were very
happy and they liked the queen very much
at the time Kenya was still part of the
British Empire soon the hotel became the
target of mommao independent Fighters
they banned it like every British
establishment they could find they have
done a mass action all over Kenya here
in the central Province I think they
decided to bank the hotel
and that's why they bunted the lodge and
then nothing was left the hotel was
burnt up to ashes it is here at the
Treetops hotel in Mount Kenya that's
Queen Elizabeth land of her father's
death and that immediately ushered her
into her new role as Queen but just a
few months down the line in October 1952
when the state of emergency was
introduced a few kilometers from here
some of the worst atrocities committed
on the mount Mao Fighters were done by
the British soldiers under the Queen's
watch
is one of the few surviving momao
Independence Fighters she still has
nightmares about the brutality of the
British soldiers
I wake up in the middle of the night
screaming when I remember the harassment
that used to take place in the forest
that fight was terribly brutal the
soldiers would Storm Into the homes
killed the young men and the children
too
asked Queen Elizabeth
for the torture she said British
soldiers inflicted upon her a video of
her calling for justice has been viewed
more than 9 million times she says King
Charles shall now take responsibility
fact just the other day I sent word to
them saying the sun should send me what
belongs to me and he should send to no
one else but Miriam mafenga who went to
fight for Kenya's Independence in the
forest
while some will take the opportunity to
write in books of condolence many
Kenyans feel these unfinished business
with their former rulers
to continue the conversation we've
invited Joshua Quincy icons onto the
program he is a political scientist and
human rights activist his areas of
research includes development politics
from a decolonial perspective he's
working on his PhD at the University of
Castle here in Germany welcome to DW
news Africa Joshua it's a good pleasure
to have you on the program
it's it's been pointed out that Queen
Elizabeth II never apologized for the
crimes that were committed uh in the
Crown's name during colonialism would
that have made a difference
yes it would absolutely have made a
difference
um and you can see that it would have
made the difference if you look at how
the members of the royal family have
actually actively sidestepped apologies
for example last year on their tour of
the Caribbean where they were medical
protests on this very issue when they
were met with demands to apologize and
they found words describing the
atrocities of enslavement and such but
they stopped chart of an apology and the
simple reason is that such an apology
could have legal consequences because
once you apologize you have admitted
culpability in ways that could find you
in court and because we've just heard
from Kenya I also want to stress the
fact that some of these issues are not
about the far past but also about very
very recent issues for example a court
case will be brought to the European
courts of Human Rights this year where
Kenyans were displaced under Her
Majesty's Reign under Queen Elizabeth
reign
um have sued after they have found no
redress in British court and have found
Norwood dress uh with the crown so this
clearly shows that yes an apology is
called for an apology would have
consequences and the people who are
demanding the apology are now seeking
other ways of redress
in Kenya a living person who could speak
to what colonialism meant for her and
and what it did in her life but if we
can broaden this out to the African
context or the the continent of Africa
what is the legacy of British
colonialism on the African continent
I mean the British Empire was one of the
largest in history and it has a lot
centuries-long reign of brutality that
stretched you know as you know across
the world but that especially impacted
Africa and Africans from the time of
enslavement uh through the time of
colonialism all the way and we should
not forget that uh to the so-called you
know postcolonial period where we again
including under the reign of Queen
Elizabeth had written meddling in
African Affairs so yes there's a long
list of brutality of displacement
there's a long list of colonial theft
and this is true for both artworks and
for natural resources this is true for
many of the most glamorous items in fact
in Elizabeth crown jewels right
um but it is also true for Wars such as
the biafran war where we had Britain
um Supply weapons to Nigeria under the
watch of Queen Elizabeth it is true for
Kenya where like I just said and like um
the mammal fighter also just iterated
um we had incredible brutality including
under Elizabeth reign
um herself so we mustn't lose sight of
the fact that this is a long history
that stretches into the present where we
have millions of people who are alive
today that are directly impacted by the
injustices by the brutality by the theft
and plunder that emanated from London
that was orchestrated by the British
Empire now the fact that this Legacy is
a questionable one also becomes very
very queer clear if we look at the way
in which Britain has dealt with this
because there was literally an operation
Legacy that was designed
um to instruct the um sorry that was
designed to actually
um instruct the colonial officials and
the foreign office workers in the former
colonies to destroy
um a lot of evidence a lot of documents
that would actually prove some of these
common atrocities and so orders were
given to destroy such documents that
would embarrass
um You Know Her Majesty's the Queen's
government and this included
um instructions that were very clear
about who should even be able to see and
access and Destroy these documents in
some cases the people were told that
only white people of British descent
should even be able to see and able to
destroy these documents because it was
clear that some of the
um you know a racist and colonial
policies that were documented there
would not just be an embarrassment but
again could be the base for legal action
Joshua what role then could Britain's
new monarch King Charles III play in in
having the British Monarchy confront and
potentially redress the country's
Colonial past
yeah it's a key question so what we're
faced with is actually a sanitized
Legacy of the crown when it comes to
Colonial history and I think the new
king is called upon to actually and
actively change that so there is a very
very clear expectation there are calls
um from both South Africa and from India
that are specifically about the crown
jewels right that are now supposed to
come into the possession of um you know
his wife Camilla and people are saying
well why should that happen they should
be transferred or some of these
incredible gemstones should be
transferred to India and South Africa
where they actually come from but beyond
that people are saying there needs to be
an apology and there needs to be
redressed we mustn't lose sight of the
fact that the crown has incredible
wealth and more than 17 billion
um US dollars are not in British
possession but in possession of the
crown and
um there are other
operations such as the duchy of Cornwall
which generates which itself is again a
multi-billion dollar more than one
billion dollar estate that generates
revenue for the royal family for its own
um use and so this is where we can see
that some of the bridges of enslavement
some of the riches of colonialism have
been invested and are still benefiting
the royal family today and that is where
people are saying this is where we need
to have redress and this actually
um precedent in the UK where we had for
example the University of Glasgow doing
a slavery audit where they try to
understand so how have we as an
institution actually benefited from
enslavement and I think the time is
right for the crown to undergo both a
slavery and the colonialism audit to
actually face up their responsibilities
oh intriguing stuff as always it's good
to have you on the program Joshua
Chrissy ikins thank you for your Insight
and for weighing in on this conversation
for us
thank you